"Gaby está comprando regalos en línea. El costo
del envío se basa en la cantidad de dinero de
la orden. Para órdenes mayores a $20 dólares el
costo del envío es de $4 dólares. Para órdenes
de $20 o más el envío cuesta $7 dólares. ¿Podemos
expresar la cantidad de dinero de la orden como
una función del costo del envío?" Nos están
pidiendo expresar la cantidad -la cantidad-
de la orden -de la orden- como una función del
costo -costo- del envío, y me preguntan si esto
se puede expresar como una función. Para que
esto sea una función, por cada costo del envío
deberemos tener un solo valor en la cantidad
de la orden. Esta es mi entrada -entrada-,
así que si tenemos nuestro costo
de envío y entra a esta cajita,
esta caja representa una relación que todavía
no sabemos si va a ser una relación o no,
deberá tener como resultado un sólo valor en
la cantidad -cantidad de la orden, cantidad de la
orden-. Veamos las posibilidades. Bueno, sólo
hay dos posibilidades en el costo del envío:
$4 dólares o de $7 dólares, ¿qué pasa si yo
ingreso 4 dólares en esta caja que podría
representar o no una función?, ¿cuál será la
salida?, ¿cuál será la cantidad de la orden? Pues
puede ser cualquier cosa por debajo de 20 dólares,
puede ser 1 dólar, puede ser 1 dólar con 50,
puede ser 7 dólares o incluso puede ser 19
con 99. Todos estos valores y muchos más
pueden estar asociados a este costo de envío,
lo mismo sucederá si ponemos 7 en la entrada,
podré tener una cantidad de la orden que puede
ser desde 20 dólares, que es el límite inferior,
hasta 100 dólares, o no sé, incluso puedo tener
1 millón, cualquier cantidad por encima o igual
a 20. Por lo que no podemos representar esto
como una función: no es función, función.